[Música]
todos queremos llegar alto pero no todos
saben lo que es estar arriba
decir que estamos arriba es como decir
que estamos bien que estamos en la parte
superior de algo o que hemos logrado un
sueño estar arriba no siempre asegura
que estemos bien por ejemplo en perú
vivir en lo más alto de un cerro es
igual a ser invisible es como reducirse
hasta convertirse en una cosita pequeña
sin necesidades y sin voz yo vivo en lo
más alto pero ni yo ni mis vecinos
estamos arriba he escuchado muchas veces
que el virus nos tocó a todos por igual
yo creo que no el virus desnudo la
realidad y esa verdad es que no todos
pudimos tener el mismo acceso a la salud
ni a la educación ni a la alimentación
cuando estamos arriba pero arriba en lo
más alto de un cerro no no tienes acceso
al agua y recordemos que una de las
mayores medidas preventivas era lavarse
las manos por más de 20 segundos y como
haces cuando tienes el agua
en tinas parecen medidas tan sencillas
pero es importante que sepan que no
todos pudimos cumplir con esos cuidados
básicos por otro lado el aislamiento en
una casa tres por tres o en una 4x4
metros cuadrados es algo imposible
muchos de los que estamos arriba hemos
convivido y dormido cerca de un familiar
o contagiado con el virus y si este
familiar moría entonces era difícil
sacar el cuerpo por la falta de acceso a
las carreteras y porque no hay recursos
es decir cuando somos pobres ni siquiera
podemos morir en paz
en medio de esta situación no podíamos
quedarnos esperando así que nos
empezamos a organizar como siempre lo
hemos hecho y con todo un trabajo de
logística los vecinos y los vecinos de
la agrupación familiar antonio raimondi
decidimos formar la olla como un nueva
esperanza del perú una olla común existe
gracias a la organización y a la
colaboración de dinero alimentos y
tiempo para que las vecinas y los
vecinos tengan un plato de comida todos
los días nuestro allí está es el refugio
de muchas personas es la esperanza de
gente solidaria es el esfuerzo de salir
adelante
colaborando con otro vecino es tomar tu
tiempo para pensar que cocinar con poco
dinero
no solo para tu familia sino para 30
familias mi nombre es hábil y abierta
ramos alcántara soy enfermera técnica
con vocación de servicio para el pueblo
hoy trabajo en una ong como promotora
social
capacitó a las mujeres para que ellas
puedan hacer denuncias y emprendan un
negocio es decir que tengan la fuerza
para romper el ciclo de la violencia me
apasiona trabajar con las mujeres tanto
que ahora soy presidenta de la red de
ollas de san juan de lurigancho es una
bendición ser compañeras y gracias a esa
unión que es que pudimos lograr que se
apruebe la ley de la emergencia
alimentaria en esta pandemia muchas se
han dado cuenta que pueden liderar
espacios y proyectos de ley yo vivo en
perú en lima en el distrito de san juan
de lurigancho y aquí hay un promedio de
500 ollas comunes que sobreviven con la
autogestión y que son lideradas por
mujeres y entre esas ollas está mi olla
nueva esperanza del perú
para conseguir los insumos hemos bajado
a los mercados a pedir alimentos
vamos al mercado productores que es el
mercado más grande de lima es como una
ciudad con los precios más bajos
llegamos a recuperar alimentos es decir
lo que ellos no logran vender en el día
nosotros lo pedimos hemos sido también
al mercado de frutas y al mercado
pesquero
personas de buen corazón como
empresarios se han sumado a la ollita ha
sido todo un reto porque las señoras de
la ollita tuvieron que aprender a usar
la tecnología para enviar las fotos
videos que confirmaban el buen uso de
las donaciones
fotos con la comida del día a grupos de
whatsapp y además tuvieron que usar las
tecnologías para ayudar en las tareas a
sus hijos a través de esas actividades
conocimos a otras compañeras para
compartir experiencias
hay muchas que no se conocen hasta la
fecha pero que a través de la necesidad
de estar conectadas somos como una red
de apoyo para las otras mujeres con las
que hemos ido conociendo en los meses de
pandemia
pero cuando vives arriba no todo es
trabajo duro y penas también disfrutamos
de momentos alegres nunca faltan la risa
y la buena comida recuerdo con mucho
cariño uno de los momentos más alegres
con mis vecinas y vecinos
que fue la celebración del aniversario
de la ollita
empezamos a cocinar el 20 de marzo del
2020 y el 20 de marzo del 2021 cumplimos
un año de trabajo al servicio de la
comunidad por el aniversario mi esposo y
cuatro vecinos
y yo decidimos hacerle una sorpresa a
las vecinas
quisimos preparar una generosa
pachamanca la pachamanca es una comida
típica de la sierra del perú y la
mayoría de mis vecinas son de la sierra
hoy siento que soy la voz de ella soy la
voz de clelia
margarita simón a vilma li lin azahar ya
olga karina y marie a ella al igual que
yo son mujeres que todo este tiempo de
pandemia han estado al servicio de la
comunidad las admiro mucho porque son
fuertes y trabajadoras una de ellas es
margarita es madre soltera
trabaja vendiendo panes desde las 4
hasta las 9 de la mañana todos los días
margarit ha sufrido mucha violencia pero
margarita tiene muchos sueños los sueños
de margarita también son mis sueños
ese día en la pachamanca todos contamos
nuestros sueños mientras los varones nos
atendían
me quedé con la sonrisa de cada una de
las señoras y no sabía que esa iba a ser
la última vez disfrutando de la sonrisa
de la vecina clelia porque al poco
tiempo falleció
todas somos migrantes que decidimos
venir a la capital de mi país para
lograr nuestros sueños vinimos atraídas
por las promesas que la capital nos
ofrecía por las mejores oportunidades
que una ciudad grande podría darnos era
las promesas de un mejor futuro y por
eso me incomoda mucho cuando la gente
ofende a las señoras para que tienes
muchos hijos nos dicen regresa a tu
chacra eres pobre porque no te esfuerzas
trabaja ociosa nosotras las mujeres y
varones de las hoyas trabajamos más de
lo que se imaginan
todas las mujeres salieron de sus
pueblos buscando ser profesionales y
tener un mejor futuro sin imaginar que
eso sería una gran mentira porque
trabajan haciendo labores domésticas
supuestamente a cambio de sus estudios
pero esa promesa nunca fue cumplida
hasta la actualidad muchas de las
vecinas no saben leer ni escribir
muchos salieron embarazadas sin
planificarlo y así suene duro algunas
tuvieron hijos por violación de sus
propias parejas quiero compartir las
experiencias de las señoras quiero que
sepa que somos trabajadoras llenas de
sueño que tenemos familia y estamos
comprometidas con la comunidad
mi objetivo es visibilizar el aporte
social que tienen las suyas comunes y
que junto a universidades empresarios
comunidad y estado podamos construir
lugares de esperanza mientras el mundo
vive a mil por hora existimos los de
arriba personas que pertenecemos a un
sector no muy visibilizado y estamos
luchando por salir adelante a través de
nuestra creatividad y solidaridad hoy
más que nunca creo que la alimentación
es un derecho no un privilegio y todos
tenemos el deber de apoyar para que
nadie nunca le falte un plato de comida
caliente